[Musica]
[Applauso]
Sono una mamma una psicologa
psicoterapeuta una professionista e per
moltissimo tempo mi sono sentita
sbagliata
da sempre amo il mio lavoro ed ha sempre
mi sono pensata una mamma
Ma quando quasi otto anni fa ho stretto
tra le braccia per la prima volta mia
figlia soprattutto nei primissimi tempi
non ho sentito quella felicità pervasiva
che pensavo fosse naturale sentire
ho faticato quasi due anni per sentirmi
pienamente profondamente una mamma la
mamma di Azzurra e questo unito al fatto
che amavo e amo profondamente il mio
lavoro come immaginerete mi ha devastata
di sensi di colpa Sono arrivata a
mettere in dubbio le scelte più
importanti della mia vita
non certo quella di essere diventata
mamma ma sicuramente quella di portare
avanti la mia carriera con dedizione con
due bambini a casa
dopo non molto tempo è arrivato Infatti
anche Manuel
per moltissimo tempo mi sono sentita
come uno scarabocchio da riscrivere come
mamma
da qualche anno mi occupo di queste
tematiche lo ammetto inizialmente anche
per scoprire se non fossi l'unica a
sentire queste sensazioni così difficili
e ho collezionato dati che oggi Voglio
condividere con voi Inizio da questo
nel 2019
37.611 mamme hanno rassegnato le loro
dimissioni sono state Il 73% di tutte le
dimissioni rassegnate nel nostro paese
l'anno dopo il dato è salito al 77%, un
altro dato interessante è che il 40.3%
delle mamme tra i 25 e i 54 anni di età
nel nostro paese non ha alcuna
occupazione
sicuramente in questa percentuale
rientrano anche donne che hanno scelto
serenamente la maternità a tempo pieno
ma sappiamo non essere la totalità del
dato
Questo significa che nel nostro paese
ancora moltissime donne rinunciano alla
carriera in virtù dell'accudimento
diventiamo mamme sempre più tardi
abbiamo raggiunto i 32.4 anni di dieta
media del primo figlio contro i 29 anni
della media europea e in Italia di figli
ne facciamo sempre meno forse saprete
che per la prima volta dall'unità
d'Italia siamo scesi sotto i 400.000
nati vivi Allora questi numeri questi
dati che ormai per me sono volti nomi
storie di tantissime mamme mi hanno
sempre molto allarmata e ho deciso di
guardarli più da vicino l'ultima ricerca
l'abbiamo promossa con l'app come uno
spin off dell'università di Firenze e
voleva Fotografare lo stato di salute
psicosociale delle mamme lavoratrici in
Italia voglio darvi già un primissimo
dato il nostro obiettivo era di
raccogliere circa 300 compilazioni
e invece pensata abbiamo dovuto fermare
l'indagine pretempo perché il sole 48
ore oltre 2000 mamme hanno voluto dirci
a gran voce come stavano abbiamo chiuso
con 2691 compilazioni complete
Siamo partiti da questa domanda la
maternità oggi per chi lavora è
sostenibile
sostenibilità secondo la Treccani è uno
sviluppo che consente la soddisfazione
dei bisogni della popolazione presente
senza impattare però la possibilità di
soddisfacimento dei bisogni delle
popolazioni future
parliamo di bisogni non di desideri
parliamo di necessità e maslo con la sua
famosissima piramide dei bisogni umani
ci ricorda che non esistono solo i
bisogni fisiologici mangiare bere
lavarsi e vestirsi dormire che già per
una mamma a volte è difficile da fare ma
l'ultima Punta il triangolo più in alto
rappresenta i bisogni di
autorealizzazione ci parla di creatività
di passioni di svolgere attività che
parlano della nostra identità personale
e badate bene senza Quella punta non
esiste alcuna piramide
non so A quanti di voi sia successo di
sopprimere un bisogno come questo per
settimane mesi anni
ti è mai capitato di non poter andare a
fare sport vedere un amico dedicarvi del
tempo di qualità oppure dedicarlo alla
vostra coppia per tutto quel tempo come
stareste
e secondo voi Quante sono oggi in Italia
le mamme che lavorano che svolgono
regolare attività sportiva che hanno e
coltivano delle amicizie che si dedicano
tempo di qualità che lo dedicano ancora
alla loro dimensione di coppia sono
poche abbiamo chiesto loro riesci a
dedicarti a delle attività come passioni
Hobby durante la settimana
e il
91.7% di quasi 3000 madri a questa
domanda Ha risposto mai o quasi mai
hanno soffocato i loro bisogni
questa indagine ci ha permesso anche di
confermare che le mamme che lavorano
sviluppano competenze psicologiche
elevate flessibilità a problem solving
ma che spesso le usano per sistemare il
mondo esterno per soddisfare i bisogni
degli altri
pagano un pegno veramente alto per
mantenere in equilibrio vita lavoro
progetto familiare quello di
dimenticarsi se stesse
91.7%. Allora mi chiedo per quanto
potranno pagare questo prezzo così alto
perché sostenibilità è una dimensione
che ci richiama al futuro Allora
facciamo insieme una proiezione di qui a
30 anni stiamo parlando delle nostre
bambine probabilmente cosa succederà se
sceglieranno la carriera senza intoppi
oppure la maternità senza Pegni da
pagare
Secondo voi una società può sostenersi
senza madri o un'economia svilupparsi in
maniera adeguata senza tutte quelle
donne nel mondo del lavoro
e secondo voi questo futuro è così
distante dal presente che vi ho appena
raccontato
per ogni titolo virtuoso che leggiamo
sul giornale per il mondo del lavoro
rispetto alla maternità esistono ancora
troppi esempi di materna Wall
stereotipi discriminazioni pregiudizi
che in un qualche modo ostacolano lo
sviluppo professionale di una mamma
E rimanendo in tema di ostacoli non
potevamo non indagare quello più famoso
e crudele dal punto di vista emotivo per
l'autorizzazione di una mamma il già
citato senso di colpa materno abbiamo
trovato ovviamente livelli medio elevati
di questa sensazione e oggi ci tengo a
fare una distinzione che c'è stata
offerta da tre autori che io stimo
moltissimo Nardone Cagnoni e Milanese ci
hanno raccontato in un recente articolo
che quando il senso di colpa si esprime
nel presente
contestualmente a un'altra situazione
come ad esempio
Ciao amore Allora senti ci vediamo dopo
Ok quando torno dal lavoro esco chiudo
la porta e sento quella sensazione che
molte di noi ora staranno riconoscendo
in quel caso non dovrai parlare di senso
di colpa perché quello che in realtà sto
provando È un grande senso di
inadeguatezza
in quel momento mi sto sentendo
inadeguata verso un comportamento che
dovrai tenere o non tenere secondo il
mio ideale di buona madre o forse dovrei
dire di madre perfetta
il mito della madre perfetta in
letteratura specialistica è molto
conosciuto è questo standard di madre
ideale che Iper performa nel mondo del
lavoro ma è anche L'Angelo del focolare
ne gestisce mille più una ma sempre con
il sorriso sulle labbra a cui Purtroppo
molte donne tendono rimanendo
intrappolate nel senso di inadeguatezza
moltissime donne per rincorrere questo
ideale di madre perfetta
trascurano la dimensione più importante
per essere una buona madre la propria
identità personale 91.7%.
Allora
un'altra risposta che mi ha molto
colpito in questa indagine è stata come
descriveresti il tuo stato attuale di
donna madre professionista se dovessi
usare l'immagine di un film Il titolo di
una canzone di un'immagine che hai visto
Ecco Era una domanda risposta aperta e
ce n'erano alcune che ritornavano tra
tutte queste mamme due o tre di queste
quella che più mi ha colpito è stata
L'urlo di Munch
vi lascio qualche secondo per dare il
vostro significato al Perché a una madre
dovrebbe descriversi con questa immagine
e io non so cosa ci vedete Ma io ci vedo
una richiesta di aiuto un urlo che
nemmeno io voglio sentire e allo stesso
tempo una richiesta di aiuto un urlo che
nessuno può sentire
il tema del Benessere individuale della
mamma come persona è poco attenzionato
Noi donne possiamo leggere un sacco di
libri entrare in contatto con tante
teorie che ci spiegano Come essere madri
migliori Come entrare in relazione con i
nostri figli ma fino a poco tempo fa
esisteva ben poco che potesse darci
strumenti psicologici innovativi
sistematizzati concreti per raccontarci
Come rimanere in connessione con noi
stesse dopo quel cambiamento epocale
ed è anche un tema complesso si può
affrontare da più punti di vista quello
economico quello sociale quello
culturale
Ma la cultura cos'è se non l'insieme di
ogni singola mente e quindi per me è
anche un tema di mindset oggi sono qui
per dirvi che se vogliamo che la
maternità sia davvero sostenibile nel
nostro paese serve una rivoluzione di
mindset
dell'approccio mentale alla maternità
del concetto stesso di maternità che
apra a un nuovo concetto di
genitorialità e per prime questa
rivoluzione la dovremo fare proprio noi
mamme perché è vero che il contesto
intorno a noi deve cambiare ma i dati
non sono molto confortanti su quanto
tempo richiederà questo cambiamento e
soprattutto Cosa succederebbe se
veramente avvenisse questo cambiamento e
noi non ci facessimo trovare pronte
Perché ancora intente a cercare il mito
della madre perfetta
Serve quindi che compiamo un cambiamento
individuale e collettivo parliamo ancora
troppo poco tra noi mamme di questi temi
ma sono ancora troppe le mamme che per
questi temi si sentono frustrate
inadeguate
sbagliate che si sentono come mi sono
sentita io come uno scarabocchio da
riscrivere come mamma
mi sono sentita così
fino a quando ho scoperto che non ero io
che dovevo essere riscritta ma era il
mio mindset la maternità Il mio concetto
di maternità che avevano bisogno di una
bella revisione quale
imparare a vivere la maternità con più
flessibilità concedendomi imperfezioni
che non tolgono niente ai miei bambini
imparare a dedicarmi a loro al 100% con
immersione fuori dai momenti lavorativi
certo non ci riesco sempre altrimenti
sarei una madre perfetta ma quando ci
riesco amplifico il tempo che ho con
loro miglioriamo i nostri ricordi il
nostro legame e imparare a concedermi
riti di cura positivi verso me stessa
perché quel tempo non è tolto ai miei
figli quel tempo permette ai miei figli
di riavere una mamma rigenerata in
energia pronta ad essere distesa nella
relazione con loro
questo cambiamento di mindset però
questo rimetterci al primo posto non può
finire con noi mamme no
perché la maternità non è un evento
individuale o famigliare
la maternità È un evento sociale i
nostri figli Le nostre figlie sono la
società
e Infatti vorrei chiedervi Chi di voi
ogni giorno oppure anche abbastanza
spesso interagisce con una mamma
guardatevi Siete tantissimi questa
rivoluzione è possibile può iniziare da
qui Da oggi da come da oggi parlerete
con quella mamma da come la guarderete
da come la osserverete da come la
vedrete
le mamme di oggi hanno bisogno di essere
viste perché forse anche in quella mamma
c'è un bisogno soffocato da anni un
senso di frustrazione di inadeguatezza
forse anche lei rincorre il mito di una
madre che non esiste forse anche dentro
di lei c'è un urlo silenzioso che
nemmeno lei sta a sentire aiutatela a
riconnettersi con la propria identità
personale e se volete che la maternità
per quella mamma e per tutte le mamme
sia davvero sostenibile da oggi non
chiedetele di essere perfetta
chiedetele solo di restare umana Stay
Human
[Applauso]